welcome to this video playing mhb with
black from the US highway 44 Sicilian
check and okay not not the most exciting
line the the check on b5 but it's a very
good good line of course very solid for
white hmm how do I play here probably
with g6 probably with g6 deform I'm just
going to play maybe I should maybe I
should play something like c4 in this
position make sure that d 4 is not
coming with the broad center okay mmm be
five or not yeah not much choice
actually
interesting should he play the oh no a
completely different stuff right see two
coming I don't know ever need to Castle
anyway I guess hmm what is the aiming
form
um
what about D 5 D 5e 594 maybe to some
this is as is an active continuation you
find hangs okay just takes hmm I am NOT
expecting a single mafia night f4 why
not controlling d3 looking at age 3 i'm
surprised that this is even possible
okay so he just okay he just accepts
that that it is a bad position with me
having the bishop pair I see yeah I
wasn't expecting this that he that he
just goes for that I'm how to play
however the bishop player Queen to e4
maybe is coming there should be six
Queenie form I'd like to move the bishop
improve it it's not good on g7 and 95 as
always some always possible a team
hmm I'm wondering about e5 should I go
for this II 5v5 then bit should be six
controlling g5 maybe yeah I've taken a
bit a bit long here for a position that
it is that is some quite okay for black
in any case i only spent a huge amount
of time here okay yeah hmm can i play f6
hero is this maybe just go where six
looks a bit shaky the Queen d5 those
kind of moves but I don't see a direct
drawback
oh wow okay i'll just play here again
come on let's get the Queen's off or the
other one maybe this one not two not
sure who write h six maybe okay let's
get the get the King King involved check
he's not he's not threatening to enter
on g7 anyway ok Knight a5 see force it's
very important here
yeah maybe you might have wrote this six
okay not ideal the time situation is is
worrisome the position is of course
fantastic that's good i can i can take
be 39 morning probably too hmm would be
nice to have a bit of time just to be
more precise
ice coming to the two
now my bloody bloody time issue has cost
me dearly him lost a huge chunk of moria
my good position here this was a
completely winning end game at the start
with their with the two bishops check
check check check check it's a droid
please game draw yeah yeah i blundered
away so much time at the start in this
descent game is is if you have time on
your hands it's just a very easy win for
black it's two bishops better King
mobile porn center I mean even with this
time I should win it it's really
disappointing that I didn't I guess I I
screwed it up yeah this is this is very
easily winning actually yeah he probably
must rate this is this is not making any
sense i take the pawn so we must take
night takes reform and now this this FYI
what is exploding here totally yeah
that's a fairly easy win this is what I
should have done you know whenever Erie
got much much more nervous than
necessary here
it's still probably winning but getting
getting trickier and trickier Bishop c4
you should see for seems to be better
they pawn really made me made me nervous
yeah and okay this this type of thing
that that this should should probably
hold for what if it's all on one one
side of the body can probably set up a
sort of fortress yeah really this is
something that really I shouldn't one he
got he he allowed this end game very
willingly I mean it's quite clear that
here widest is almost losing i mean very
very bad at least losing is too much
maybe night age six or something but the
way you played this it was very close to
losing around here this is a position
you're not you won't hold in any any
sort of longer time control it's just
just too much of an advantage for black
okay thanks for watching